Murr is coming in what's up Murr they
throw them Impractical Jokers of course
what's going on man how are you I'm
great how are you guys good so we were
talking you know a lot of us here watch
the show pretty regularly and we were
talking about how this book has been
something that you've been teased about
on the show for not having it come out
that's dude for a long time
absolutely so that big circle things
going on yeah that's what I hear nothing
there's nothing oh I am up oh yeah now
that way the volume is not on you we
should have we should have had that for
you you go so uh so yeah they've been
teasing me for years about this book you
know you've seen it they know that I'm
not published the story of it is this
cuz you've been trying to do it since
college
yeah well I wrote the book almost 15
years ago okay I spent a year of my life
writing but yeah I got a degree in
English I can write a book you know
right so I spent a year writing it but
the guys and I you know the story of us
we're regular guys we've no no nothing
we didn't know anybody we had no cousin
the visitors just worked hard right so
you can write a book yeah but you can't
publish you know in like 14 years ago
there was a self-published publishing
guys it wasn't what it is today you know
so so I sent it out to every publisher
and it can return to me unopened unn
opens why unopened because the I do have
an agent to represent me so they
wouldn't even consider unsolicited
unsolicited submission gratitude which
was my nickname in college things I
don't take people sending key then all
the sudden if you do something that
arrived them they sue you it to take a
[ __ ] weird position for did that make
you feel better than your rejections
were coming back sealed meaning they
hadn't actually rejected the material
right you as a human yeah there's your
name made me feel worse made me feel
like I had no ability to even get to
decision but you know me like right it
made me realize how far I was from the
the goal right now and and then honestly
I got like a hundred like just returns
and I just put in my computer and it's
sat there for a decade and a half so so
when I get when I get crap from the guys
they've never except for queue they've
never read the book right there was in a
good and and it's not
never got rejected they just you know I
had no agent what did you say about it
cute loved it okay but the restaurant
did not support you did not read the
book Oh Joe Joe Joe in typical Joe
fashion Joe's like I sent him the book
early but I could really use your help
here you know what do you think is good
you know and he goes well okay I read it
I was like what do you think he goes
well I didn't care for the middle I was
like all right well that's that's good
feedback what what about the middle what
what didn't work he was the very middle
I was he okay just specifically what
very middle he goes the middle word I
was like the middle word he was yeah I
didn't think you needed the middle word
you could take it out I said what was
the middle word he goes extraneous I
said you think the word extraneous was
extreme single word and Sal and sounds
not interested cells not interested in
me in general eyes how do you uh how do
you maintain cuz like you know we come
from radio where we've watched
partnerships dissolve like success for
something for some reason in radio yeah
for the most part success completely
destroys partnership and yeah I mean me
and Anthony were really hard to work
with yeah but how do you guys but you
just said Sal is not interested in you
whatsoever you guys stop yourselves from
being at each other's throats and been
like look this is a real good thing the
four of us have got to stick together
I've been pine pining for Sal's
attention for 28 years you know I think
what's different about us is you know
guys know our story we've been friends
since 1990 we went to all-boys school
and I in high school in Staten Island
that Bond's you for a life you know
right I think at this point we're just
too old to make new friends
you guys ever fight yeah I mean
constantly yeah sometimes huge blowouts
where we don't speak for a week you know
like it sad things I threatened to like
actually [ __ ] [ __ ] up the the no I think
no I don't think so I think you're cool
has always prevail you know and we
realize that what we're creating
together is we're still having a so much
fun yeah right you know let's open up
these avenues like you can actually get
this book published you got a movie
coming out now you got the the cruise
that you do like it's it's kind of
amazing that the show has been so sick
test for that you guys and the people
around you have been able to figure out
how to get branched this thing out to
every possible you smart man you very
smart to do it yeah you know the cool
thing too is that you when something
gets you down you get pissed off
you remember that the there are three
other guys that are depending on you for
the different things and that kind of
normalizes you to you know you know no
one of us gets out of control or it has
too big of an ego cuz you're the three
best friends just kind of rip rip you
right down right you normal that's why
the guys and I've never like all of this
stuff going on our lives hasn't really
changed the our relations I or our
personalities when you're doing gigs
there too because you guys to do it like
they do big live gigs but you're also
depending on three other people to not
get sick like it's like you got three
yeah to help everybody shows up on time
yeah and you guys are all pretty good at
being there on time and being because
for a gig like in a band or never like
the one cokehead the lead showing up at
the last minute no Sal and Q live in
Stein Islands yeah you know so they have
to do with the goddamn BQE every day you
know to come to set so that then that
that causes a little bit of chaos in the
filming the show but no I think we're
pretty responsible all the time and the
thing is to in the TV show we created a
TV show unfortunately we're all formers
have to be on camera at the same time
right there's no like you show for your
scene right now one or two later my call
time is this I call times the same and
our rap time is this same every single
day how much writing goes into it
because it feels like you guys obviously
write the pranks right and then kind of
make it up as you go once you get there
or that kind of just the design
everything is pretty much written we
come up with the challenge ideas right
and we have a team of our best friends
that help us in pitch ideas to us we
come with the challenge ideas then we
put together like a bunch of jokes ideas
of what could happen mm-hm
things are we won't dry and we keep
those packets from each other you know
what I mean so so Sal doesn't know what
I'm going to give him or Joe doesn't
know what I'm good you know so and so
for sure and and then honestly we throw
half of it out the window and yeah I say
how do you get 80% of it is just
improvised
and in the moment what I feel how hard
is it get to the more famous you guys
get people recognize you it happens but
you know it's New York City you know is
ten million people here is not that hard
right
the movie was hard you know we just
finished shooting the Joker's movie
about a week ago that was harder because
is a travel movie so we're hitting a lot
of towns up and down the east coast
small towns and ward spreads people
start showing up that was harder to do
yeah and I would imagine to like you
used to do everything at the Palisades
Mall ya know I would imagine you can't
really go to the palace no more we
switched malls every season for that
exact reason yeah people start just
showing up public you want to see us
yeah so is the movie explain that is the
movie like a long episode is it it's
it's bigger than that it's it's a it's a
like a cross-country up and down the
East Coast you know it's a is it up and
down the east coast road trip movie
mm-hmm it is like Impractical Jokers and
that there's hidden camera challenges
throughout but there's a narrative
beginning and end that gets sets us on
this journey like Borat in a way we're
something happening but there's a reason
to be moving yeah exactly right it's got
a lots of I will say this is not
hyperbole this is coming from my heart
I've never been more embarrassed in my
life than one specific thing they did to
me in the movie it in 88 years of
filming the TV show what they do
McKellar was just down the hall I didn't
like a thing I was reliving that anxiety
one show pose in front of her naked
Annika McHale her played Winnie Cooper
Oh Wonder Years
murrs crush and on one episode so like
the way I don't know the way the
episodes work is that throughout the
episode the guys do challenges one guy
ends up losing so he ends up having to
do the humiliation at the end of the
episode so former one episode they told
him the big humiliation is you're gonna
have to be in a body bodybuilding
competition yeah and he's like oh no
greased me up yeah a little-little
speedo on me you know have the kind of
body shouldn't be naked in the shower
there's like weird right
so he's all greased up he's got an edge
white and blue speedo on and then they
push him in a room and he finds out it's
not a bodybuilding competition he's
there for Danica McKellar depressed day
and he's gotta interviewed and the
questions like the index card he's got
to do this interview with her so if you
can imagine what they did to me in one
particular moment in the movie was about
a hundred times more power so that's
really oh my god
yeah I can't say too much about it
except I will give you a little tease
and yeah the tease I didn't real I
didn't even know they were filming the
movie we were done shooting that day and
so it was my regular life and was
something they did to me Mario it was
actually part of the movie well there
was another one I mean wasn't it you
that you thought you were on your way to
get your dad or something like that or
or on your way to set and they ended up
driving him onto one of those boats that
takes cars and so he ended up just in
his car on a boat he's like what the
[ __ ] is going on and that's when they
dropped a bomb on him that this is
actually a challenge and we're gonna put
you on a little like dinghy thing right
next to the Statue of Liberty the rest
of the session you have to dress the
Statue of Liberty and wave to all the
tourists stupid cruise boats are going
by and none of the people on the boats
are looking at the Statue of Liberty
they're looking at the idiot standing in
the middle of water on a date with no
boats around you guys have a good
whoever road goes you're behind the
scenes like location stuff there's a
good job getting you guys access to
stuff because if you do like if you
asked it in New York City oh my god sit
in the water while boats go by look you
want to have a good locations person who
handles that dude I couldn't believe the
one that did they showed because I mean
the shows on constantly on truTV it's
amazing but I turned it on last night
and it was the episode where one of the
guys they put him you know the tram that
goes from like Roosevelt Island
so they put one of the guys they
strapped him to the roof of the tram and
then they stopped the tram halfway so
it's our swingin you know and and [ __ ]
and they just made it swing and bah blah
but I couldn't believe that you guys got
that kind of access to the trams and
that you stopped up and I [ __ ] do you
get to them to let you although they
film stuff up there night Nighthawk said
it was you know was filmed up there with
Stallone so maybe they've done using his
own privately owned
that's how really know Joey's not part
of the MTA it's a privately owned
company that does it as I get it but we
made Joe dresses captain we called him
captain fatbelly he's got a huge gut
right we put him this like ridiculous
costume like with a cape and everything
and and as other trams are going you
know the trims are still moving away as
the trams are going boy he he's dead
he's gone he's sat on the roof right
he's going he's like a New Jersey suck
it
yeah suck it he's turning around some
Danny yeah he's like strapped to it
but he's still and you can see the mini
he takes his hands off the thing -
crotch chop he's gonna fall down he's
like crotch rot get me the [ __ ] out of
here yeah that's horrifying
it's horrifying it's horrifying I was
looking at that going like no you
wouldn't do it I could never I don't
know I've done the tram a couple of
times I don't like it but frightens me
but they made you skydive right the
other they threw me having a place and I
had cried I've 14,000 feet yeah but they
didn't you didn't know your skydive no I
the crazy part about it was like I
called my mother
right before I before I did I was in
tears right I called my mom she said we
don't know because she was at Macy's
shopping like come on it's my time and I
died she's like at Macy's can't talk is
there anything that they've done to you
that uh has gotten you pissed well I
mean they had a friend of mine give me
two prostate exams that write something
right they have this dog you know push
them into a room the same room
coincidentally that I did the deck of a
killer punishment and they pushed me to
your room there's a room full of hundred
guys Doc's are up there talking about
men's health I was like ah I see where
this is going
and they said Mauro we have to do was
ask is volunteer when he asked for
volunteer and the doctor says you know
it's important as you get older to get
prostate exam like all volunteer and the
doctor what you don't know when you're
at home watching on TV is that that
doctor is not no regular doctor he's a
buddy of mine for the past 15 years who
happens to be a doctor
so they had a friend of mine give me two
prostate exams on TV I don't know if I
were not to have Collins dumb fingers in
my ass which stupid Bob because because
on some level you would know that like
this is hilarious television but on
another level you're like I don't want
that guy's fingers in my ass right now
but another thing and the third thing is
not my dumb friend has to finger my ass
forever bond you like him and his wife
and I we swore to dinner and and I'm
like his fingers absolutely did you push
back a little I would have [ __ ] to them
just make noises the whole time because
I what is your book about the book is so
it's called awakened as I said a wrote a
14 years ago the idea is this in the
near future
New York City builds a new extension of
the Z train in downtown and they connect
finally connect Staten Island with the
subway system and all the borough's
underneath the East River they build
this underwater visitors pavilion like
glass steel super high-tech the
inaugural run of the Train when the
train rolls into the pavilion on the
trains the mayor's wife and like a
hundred lucky New Yorkers that won the
lottery they get to ride the Z train for
the first time the new one when the
train rolls into the pavilion under
water all the passengers are missing the
cars are covered in blood and the
windows are shattered outward so this
great mystery what happened in that
subway tunnel and what you come to
realize the mayors of course is in panic
his wife was on the train all the
passengers still alive what's going on
and what you come to realize that what's
happening underneath the New York City
is far far more terrifying than anything
you ever imagined so when you have
something like this that you're sitting
on right you're like I won't this is my
work this is what I want the world to
see and instead it's like oh yeah I
remember when you had to sneak a
person's french fries off your plate and
eat them are you going like yeah I know
I I do more than just steal people
french fries on TV no I mean
creativity's creativity there's no limit
to what I create and I've always loved
horror I'm a huge horror fan and I used
to love the TV show 24 you know oh my
god like this this book reads like the
very best 12 episodes of 24 you know not
the BS episode by the way what nobody on
the radio case I died
Travis's [ __ ] and holding a pen
Rachel I know your it was your nod of
agreement mer I'm with you yeah 24 is
NaN Rachel not of a great actor yeah
Travis has a big key this other one that
it should be too yeah I'm worried about
but so the minute you the minute you go
like we you know we know 24 it's a great
show Travis goes it is myrrh holding
that pen and nodding the sadness by the
way like yeah do some like gentlemen of
similar ilk yeah usually like the TV
show fringe yeah but for us it's like
fringe meets 24 oh that kind of pace I'm
gonna read it what do you guys do you
did Madison Square Garden right we
played we sold them a cigar that's
incredible I got a tattoo on my ankle
I got an ankle tattoo is this MSG in the
date of it Wow so cuz we did yeah you
know 10 years ago 12 years ago we
to show in Manhattan no joke two people
bought tickets he has brought two people
they were students of mine at the time
they spent five bucks each on tickets we
cost $65 in rent for theater so we lost
fifty five dollars four ways and then so
you know I mean as a performer to go Tim
that's a Madison Square Garden and we
remember that night 12 years ago what do
you do on the on the live show like what
is what is a Madison Square Garden
Impractical Jokers show it's a um comedy
show the four of us on stage and giant
screen behind us were shut hidden-camera
challenges you can always see on the
life it's basically honestly it's a lot
of them just ripping on me ripping on
each other you know and everything you
love about the TV show individual
standup
sal de sal de solo stand up as well we
all kind of like have a different risk
used the best writer out of us he's
doing a graphic novel right now sal de
solo stand up as well as of course our
collective sent up joe does a huge
anti-bullying campaign and pet-adoption
does a lot of work with charity and he
basically produces Impractical Jokers
and then my interests are things like
this I love the book this is a trilogy
by the way it's gonna be a new book
every every year it's fabulous do you
have the other two written I'm writing
two now we have two and three sketched
out entirely okay
chapter breakdowns now just got to write
the damn thing what's the conversation
like with truTV when you when you start
out it's like truTV is this little
network you're a little show like they
probably throw a little bit of money at
you and it's like yeah go have fun guys
when you get to the point after a few
seasons where you're like okay guys
we're the network now yeah that's it is
there is there a is there a cash-in
conversation where you're like it's time
for you guys to either name the network
after us yeah because we're the whole
thing we want more money are you gonna
give us a ton of money well you know
they've been great partners I will say
that there and into that when I pitched
the show right like my job outside
Joker's I used to run development for
the past 12 years for a TV company right
so when I went out to pitch the show to
their credit they do we had like two
different networks competing for the
show right and MTV and truTV and to
their credit they said to us years ago
if you come with if you go with us we'll
make you guys the face of the network
and they were true to the Birdman no Jim
yeah what a smart move to go that key
that's a brave move to everybody and not
empty the crazy thing was the MTV wanted
the show but not us
wanted they wanted to recast over the
younger kids whatever and make it like a
five day a week a game show Oh stink so
stupid but the thing is when you sell
that's called like a strip show they
call it five days a week all right when
you sell a show five days a week like
that that's big money if you if in
success like Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire or some writers in five days
a week you crank them out and as a
producer you can make a lot of money
it's like the the holy grail of game
shows I sell so for and we all had real
jobs or accused fireman Joe Sal owned a
bar Joe's a Salesman I worked in TV
development so it was a real debate like
do we just sell this to them and keep
our lives and get that bruise your money
but check coming in but it might not
last for long anyway it might be one
season and done correctly and it's not
something like you can't it's a little
bit more difficult to jump off of that
success because your faces are not
exactly right and so now and we took the
gamble and I mean thank God okay
great move man that's so smart it's
brave to go with them just because MTV
was MTV you know they made like [ __ ]
the Jersey Shore and they make all these
you know yeah it really is funny the way
some shows like that work because you
know you worry about overexposure yeah
but like there's a real small handful of
shows your shows one of them
I think shark tanks one of them that
like you turn on the channel and you
expect it to be on yeah when it's any
shot like when you turn on truTV and
it's not Impractical Jokers like why is
there another show on let's go to some
calls Chris in Rochester what's that pal
hello James s Murray how you doing today
good bud how are you man
great oh listen I'm a loyal Jim and fan
fan but I'm also a die-hard Impractical
Jokers man my son is 10 years old he has
autism friends are not a very common
thing for him
he finds comedy to be kind of a good
outlet and he's not a big slapstick
comedy fan but he's too young for me to
you know put him in front of a Jim
Norton special and let him watch that
kind of stuff I know that's all you need
is the boy laughing
it's about time it was too childish and
poorly written form but what's great
about idea is it's such a great
in-between you get a little bit of a
plastic and some of the stuff
inappropriate I know you guys are coming
here in Rochester
I know gambler and I can't take only ten
well I just want to let you know man
like you guys have really provided him
with just been out right where he has a
commonality especially when you can go
on the internet YouTube videos with
other Tiffany liked him there finds a
show interesting and I we just brought
your book yesterday Thanks and so I get
emotional you guys don't really helped
my son and I and a lot not what a social
development but just helping them feel
like a normal kid at times and I've
turned that to cry but your dad's show
it's so stupid it's just a common show
but they're really it provides him
something that makes him feel normal
that means a lot to me that means a lot
to me I'll tell you know when we created
the show we had no we thought were just
being screw-ups we're like you know a
couple of middle-aged guys and we're
creating like a prank show
we had no clue that it would become like
a family show that like that the
grandparents watch the kid that penny
yeah the teenagers watch and select the
show they all agree on so I don't take
that lightly like it means a lot to me
that you say that and and I know that
you bought the book because you believed
in the guys and I you believe that we're
good guys and then you want to support
us you know our story and that means a
lot to me too and I I will get to that
video the videos talk about is that if
you buy a book and send me the proof of
purchase yeah yeah I'm not taking your
word for it yeah you said approve
purchase you awakens novel at gmail.com
I then will send you a video of your
choosing you know you I'll say basically
the gist of what you want whatever you
want oh boy are you gonna regret that
yeah right I did 600 Father's Day mess
of IDEO 's
last weekend 600 and then so anyways and
verse along each one like 30 seconds a
minute yeah I'm improvising and you said
before to you're also okay with
anti-semitic stuff homophobic stuff
you'll say anything right just to spice
it up the same person
you've also the Impractical Jokers tour
that's going on right now winds up or or
ends up this weekend right the Santiago
Santa's tour ends this weekend Sunday
and in the Virginia and North Carolina
yeah yeah and then in August beginning
of August we start the new tour the
crown just Macbeth ketball world through
her we do this bit on the show where we
you know we're in Waiting a room and you
have to call out fake names of people
that aren't in the room it says such as
Quran just basketball or doctor shrimp
Puerto Rico or this fat [ __ ] is there a
[ __ ] here